>>> VOTERS IN WYIN TO
THFOYCCHFI FOR
CHALLENGER.  A
ELECTION WASN IS
INSIDIOUS.
IT ENSURES DONALD TR OPEN
GET AMERI TO ABDON
THEIR PRINLSTHIS IS DONALD TRUM
IN CONGRESS AND THISION LLIT HER
IT YOU.
WYOMINRVESOICE IN
, OUR WAY OF AENT POLLWS
FAR BE
SHULD BE THEE
REPUBLIC VIMPEACH ARY IFT
R
RETIREMENT.
DOS F  HERLETET  POINT.
WH HAVING BEEN ON THE GROUND?TRY
>> ALMOST EVER
REPUBL I TO WAS
AIT
BOE OF TIMONE
HOLD TRUMP ACCOUNTABLE,
N'WA
I SHE'S ON  AND EVIDENCE SHE'S
END  NOT.
THEY ALSO REPEATED LIES ABOUT
EL.
WHEN YOUHE W NUMBER OF A
BELIEVE THE OTHER STATES.EFRAUDO
S NO WAY JOEHAVE WON.
WHAT'S ALSO STRIKING WAS EVERY
SILE DEMOCRARTTOFOR ENEY IN THAI
ENTI REASONING WASR WORK ON THE
COMMITTEE AN UP
FOR THE TRUTH. EAT UNLESS YOU'R
ONLY 15% OF
POPULATION IS REGI
ISKNOWS ALL OF THIANSHE'S VERYTO
WHY?
WHAT'S GOING THROUGH YOUR -- AND
A
RATIONALFATHER KIND OF
REIE
S A THREAT
TNT.
BUT THERE'S ALSO AENTIAL
2024.
IT'SARMA DeSANTIS SEOUMOR LOSIN.
CHENEY WOULD
IS THAT THGOAL, INGAME NOW
THEDONALD TRURO
N.TED STATES
THAT DRIVING HER
SHE STANDS FORD R CIPAL AND WHA
HE.
S OKAY WH
I E'S ANOTHER POSSIBILITY TO CO
AT ROUTE AS
INDEPENDENT
A BL
SEN ICANATESISIF SHE RANT ASD
DONALD TRUMP ENDS UP BEING THE
NOMINEE FOR THE REPUBLICANS,LOO
VO
VOTES FS, SHE'S
HI FROM
BIDEN IS INTENNG TE THE. HATUNG
THERE IS ANOTHER PRIMARY O
TUESDAY.
MARIO, I WANT TO START WITH YOU?
SHE HAME R AND
CELEBRITY.
RIAT YE OF THE RAC
AGAINCELEBRITY, ET CETERA, SHE
ESSENTIALLY THE PROTOTRUS L IN .
THE QUESTION IS IF SHE
CONGRESS BIG ENOUGR HER AN
MARJORIE TAYLOR GRIN
WING OE PARTY AS WT'S WHAT WAS T
ASK YOU, YOU ON TH
L BUILDING FOR YEARS.
A  FASCINATION ATHCEBRFRESHMAN S
ST N CONGRESS, BUT I
KNOW IF YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
SAE E
A BACK BENCH MEMBER OF T
>> IT'S INPARE
IT WITH DON YOUNG, FORMECONGRE
NS OF LLARS BACK TALASKA.
HE OF THROLIFIC ND RAISERSIATINA
OF MONEYD DOES PALIN
HAVEHOCHOPS, DOES
HAUENCE AM
MBERS IF SHE DOES
WIN AND ABLE TO SEND ANDONEY BA
PALIN WILL PROBABLYA LOT OF A